all right let's jump into on chain
metrics first up is we have the total
supply held by long-term holders what's
going on here
yeah so um you know last week and
following this week we've reached new
all-time highs and uh the amount of
bitcoin that long-term holders possess
you know which is obviously a really
good sign because long-term holders
historically kind of set the floor
um you know when you look at this as
just a percentage of circulating supply
it's about 68
67.7 if you want to be exact
and then when you use
instead of circulating supply as the
denominator if you use adjusted supply
which is factoring out lost coins
and so just for listeners glass node
just uses a seven year threshold so over
that they consider those coins lost
and so using that as the denominator
you're looking at 84.5 of
adjusted supply
but yeah so the point is um long-term
holders are buying like crazy here
not only that but
they're also um
we're also seeing short-term holders
aging past that that 155-day threshold
and that's that's shown by by huddle
waves
so what you see is that um in the
smaller portions the younger portions of
of coins so you know when you look at um
below six months
those are going down while you're
starting to see a larger portion go into
those uh you know three to six month
six to twelve month one to two year uh
cohort so you're starting to see not
only just once and holders buying here
but also you know the investors the
entities that came on the network you
know
you know three to three six months ago
are now starting to age into that
long-term cohort um so the combination
of both of those things is why you're
showing this new all-time high
got it and so when we start thinking
about the short-term holder long-term
holder percentage we're seeing basically
the exact same thing right
i'm sorry would you say
the short-term holder long-term holder
percentage is basically the exact same
thing
yeah exactly it's just um you know
looking at
the the percentage of supply held by
long-term holders both in terms of
circulating supply and the adjusted
supply
all right and so we've got the realized
cap huddle waves explain to everyone
what this is and then what are you
seeing in the actual numbers
yeah this is just
illustrating that not only is it
long-term holders that are buying that's
contributing to the to the increase in
their in their supply but also cohorts
that are aging into that 155-day
threshold and so you can see that here
with the hotter waves that you know the
smaller the smaller i should say younger
cohorts are going down while the older
ones are moving up so you're seeing the
aging of those coins into the upper
threshold so for example you know a coin
in the in the one week to one month
threshold is not moved so now it's
moving into the one month to three
months and etc so you're starting to see
strong maturation which is a good sign
people are coming on the network buying
their coins and holding them strong
spent output age bans
yeah this is just looking at um
different different cohorts of age and
the amount the percentage of outputs
that that came from that specific cohort
that makes sense so what what i have
been looking for um is you know are
these long-term holders taking exit
liquidity that would be concerning to me
and we did actually get a spike up to
like 18 and 0.75 percent um you know
that seems to kind of been a one-off
thing uh and that spike was really in
three to five year holders in two to
three years as well
um but since then that's cooled off now
that you know we're back down to 3.4 as
as of yesterday so
it seems like so far that that that was
just you know a one-off thing that some
of these longer-term holders were
briefly taking profits but just watching
this closely to see if you know if this
kind of becomes a trend um
on tuesday i sent out a newsletter and
basically just said hey look you know
i'm feeling kind of cautious here when
we had this you know failed breakout
about 50k kind of rejected there that in
confluence with seeing some coins coming
out to exchanges a drop in a liquid
supply and then also some of this
selling from longer term holders kind of
taking profits on into the rally which
isn't completely unexpected um i was
kind of suspecting we saw some some
short-term uh you know price correction
uh and we did go down to about you know
whatever 46 300 but um it seems like we
kind of found a local bottom there i
tweeted something about that yesterday
but now today it seems like
jay powell has kind of given us the
juice
to maybe start heading back upwards um
we're also seeing a tick back up in um
both the exchange flows so coins are
moving back out of exchanges again um
and then also the liquid supply has
moved back up so um kind of the the
concerns that i have there and in the
letter i sent out tuesday have kind of
been alleviated
the entity adjusted asol uh seems to be
showing a pretty rapid recovery as well
uh last couple of days
yeah this is
very similar to the spin output h bands
it's looking at once again like the
average age of the coins being sold and
so what you don't want to see here is
what you know if you look back at late
2017 early 2018 you see that big spike
after all-time highs when when we
started it's a little off because it's a
moving average but that that spike
really came on that on the dead cat
bounce which is actually a little bit to
the right in the chart uh but point is
you know once again you don't want to
see everybody jump ship it's not you
know it's completely expected to see
people taking profits on the move up um
but you know don't want to see everyone
just sell out at once uh and so you know
you'll see all the way on the right hand
to the screen we're starting to get this
move back up in a sole but
you know kind of just monitoring this
day-to-day want to make sure we don't
see any massive move up in that to that
would tell me that you know everybody is
abandoning ship kind of like late 2017
got it and so then when we start to look
at
things like the futures dominance
obviously this shows how much kind of
leverage is in the system or is one
indicator of that
explain what you're seeing here
yeah so
most people like to look at funding to
say okay you know funding is positive so
price has to go down funding's negative
so the price has to go up like i think
there's a there's a little bit more
nuance than that um so like funding is
slightly positive
which in theory you know when you have
prolonged positive funding that tends to
be a bearish thing when you have
prolonged negative funding that tends to
be a bullish thing um but that doesn't
necessarily mean every time funding is
positive price is going to go down or
vice versa you know we had like six
months of prolonged positive funding uh
towards the you know late last year
early this year um you know there's
several things here to kind of unpack
like firstly
funding is although it is slightly
positive it's nowhere near where it was
earlier this year at similar price
levels
um also you know when you look at what
you just mentioned about the
interest dominance this is just
comparing
open interest to market cap and just
taking like a basic ratio of that and so
when when open interest really is
insignificant compared to market cap the
odds of futures having a real effect on
the price is is lower not to say that
it's impossible that we get a squeeze
but i think the chances are a lot lower
than many people are saying um also that
the red line that in the chart you just
had popped up that's the uh the leverage
ratio so it's just looking at open
interest compared to
how many coins are on that specific
exchange to kind of get a ballpark as to
like how collateralized traders are uh
both of these things are still kind of
mild so um i don't think we get any
crazy you know uh short or long squeezes
got it and then when we start to
actually go into like net realized
profit loss or a realized profit
realized loss um you've got this kind of
four part chart uh what exactly are you
looking at here what are you seeing
yeah so in the top left you have the net
realized profit loss so the difference
between the two um on the right and the
top right you've realized profits bottom
left realized losses and then bottom
right is the percent of addresses that
are in profit so
um what i'm looking for is you know like
we touched on earlier it's to be
expected that you're going to see
profits taken on the way up that's what
happens in bull markets long-term
holders distribute into strength um but
what i don't want to see is is the
overhead supply start to come onto the
market um and so
you know we had this really large
distribution zone between 50 60k we
trapped around for whatever two three
months before we started moving down
and
what you don't want to see is that
overhead supply store to come onto the
market and add in additional cell
pressure so i'm watching realized losses
to see if those coins from above are
starting to move down here
which doesn't seem to be the case it
seems to be mostly just realized profits
which is a good sign um also the
percentage of addresses and profit is
kind of important because
you know the longer that the longer that
the market stays below people's cost
basis the more likely they are to
capitulate in theory so the fact that
we've gone up from 69 at the lows to 86
percent of address is now in profit is
is a really good sign um yeah i'd like
to see continuation of that and then
like kind of on a similar note looking
at sober this is once again looking at
the profit taking of coins um we're back
above the one threshold which means the
market's trading in a state of profit
which is once again a really good thing
um and so this is the weekly version
that i threw in the newsletter but also
if you look at the daily version um we
got a bounce off of one uh whatever two
days ago when we had this little mini
correction uh which is a good sign
because it's showing that uh investors
aren't willing to sell out a loss so
kind of using those things in tandem but
still prayer is a good gauge to say okay
like are our investors um
you know are market participants willing
to start selling at a loss do they want
to get out of the market that bad it
doesn't seem like that so far because of
the we've gotten a balance off of one
twice over the last two weeks
got it and then we start to look at the
transaction uh volumes i know that at
one point you were a little worried
because it seemed like the number of
transactions was uh trending downward it
seems like those are recovering
um
like slightly but i'm still a little
concerned about it because it's it's
pretty much just ghost town i mean we've
gone off the lows that we were at like
you know last month but when you look at
like the transaction fees which is a
good uh kind of proxy for like uh you
know block space demand that s continues
to move down but the number of
transactions and also the active
addresses that this kind of moved up a
little bit but still nothing that that
you know
the way i worded in the newsletter was
we've had a big swing in price but no
dang yet and transaction activity so i
want to see some follow through on that
and some people have been saying that
it's because of all that you know all
small uh transactions are moving to
lightning network which is possible but
um you know i think
there's no real way to exactly quantify
that so
it's hard to say and then also uh we are
seeing really strong highland behavior
so you know it could partially have
something to do with that people just
don't want to transact their btc and
we're just seeing people you know buying
and holding their coins like when you
think about the network do you think of
you know this is just a rhetorical
question for listeners do you think of
usage of the network as transactional
activity or do you think of it as
hotline right um i guess some people
have different answers some people say
it's a combination of both um i
personally think the bitcoin networks
you know considering usage of it would
be huddling and if you think of it that
way you're seeing usage of the network
at all time highs but if you are
considering it
using using transactional information
then we are kind of in this uh kind of
stalemate ghost town where you know it
is a bit concerning to see and something
you definitely kind of want to see pick
up over the next couple weeks if we get
more price continuation
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you